[موسيقى]
أجنبية
هناك علاقة قوية بين
الأسئلة الأخيرة التي كانت لديك حول
المسؤولية، لذلك نحن محظوظون
عبر التاريخ لأننا
نمتلك كل هذه الأشياء هنا
ونحن في وضع جيد جدًا لإظهارها
الثقافات ولكن هذه أيضًا
هدية لا أكسبها ولكن يجب علي
رد الجميل لأولئك الأشخاص الذين
ليسوا في نفس الوضع اليوم، لذا
فهي مسؤولية خاصة أيضًا تجاه
البلدان الأصلية، هذه الأشياء التي
عملت بها لسنوات عديدة  في الترميم
والبحث عن مدن في
الشرق الأوسط،
هناك العديد من الأماكن
الرائعة جدًا والآن أرى أن أشياء كثيرة
تنهار
أنا وأصدقائي عندما عشت
في سوريا على سبيل المثال كان لدي أصدقاء رائعون
يقومون بذلك  علم الآثار والبحث عن
المدن الهادئة،
لذلك عندما كانوا في جميع أنحاء العالم
فكرت ماذا يمكنني أن أفعل لأن لدي
مسؤولية لذلك طلبت أن نجتمع أولاً
ثم نبدأ
مشروع توثيق لسوريا حتى يكون
لدينا الكثير من المعرفة ولكن هذا
المعرفة منتشرة على نطاق واسع مثل الناس،
فلماذا لا نجمعها معًا
وبدأنا قاعدة بيانات حول تراث
سوريا في لحظة إعادة الإعمار
ولكن عندما جاء المزيد والمزيد من الناس،
أخبرني أصدقائي ستيفن
لماذا لا تفعل شيئًا ما  للسماح لهم
بالعمل في المتحف وكان هناك
ضحك من أين نحصل على الأموال لذلك
نحن بحاجة إلى الدفع للأشخاص الذين
يعملون في المتحف وقد وجدوا فجأة
بعض المال ثم بدأنا في القيام
بجولات باللغة العربية لجميع تلك
الكاميرات الإخبارية للقادمين الجدد  بالنسبة لبرلين
وأنا في البداية كنت أتساءل قليلاً كيف أن
هذا العمل جديد بالنسبة لنا وعادةً
لا نحب أن يتحدث الآخرون عن
التاريخ لأنهم يخطئون كثيرًا
في أرقام السنوات
والبرج لذا لا يفعلون ذلك  ربما تكون
الأرقام صحيحة وما إلى ذلك ولكن بعد ذلك
لاحظت أن هذه كانت أفضل فكرة لدينا على الإطلاق
لأنهم لا يتحدثون
اللغة فقط كما هو الحال في فينيكس،
لذا فإن كل شخص لديه لغة ثقافية وأفراد
عائلتي يعملون مع بشار
وصايمة  إنهم يلتقون باللغة الثقافية
أيضًا وفجأة كان لدينا 16000
شخص عادة في سوريا لا
يذهبون إلى المتحف بالضرورة، لقد جاءوا
إلى المتحف وبقوا لمدة ساعة،
وبقوا لمدة ساعتين، ثم عادوا
وكان الأمر رائعًا  تجربة
لمعرفة أن هناك جوعًا للثقافة، وقد تأثر
الناس القادمون
لرؤية أن هذا جزء من تاريخي
وكانوا على اتصال مباشر
بالفضاء، لذا لا نتحدث عن
التاريخ العسكري في الشرق الأوسط الإسلامي القديم والشرق
الأوسط الإسلامي  نحن نتحدث
أيضًا عن الشرق الأوسط المسيحي
وألمانيا اليوم ونجري اتصالًا حتى
يتمكن الناس من رؤية مكاني الجديد
في مكاني القديم، إنهم متصلون
ويمكنني الاتصال بكليهما للعثور على نوع
الموطن الثقافي للبدء في الحصول على  ندخل إلى
البيئة الثقافية في برلين
وهذه هي المشاركة وأعتقد أن
الديمقراطية تقوم على المشاركة لذلك نحن
بحاجة إلى العمل كمجتمع نحتاج إلى
المشاركة وهذه هي الطريقة الأولى
لجعل الناس جزءًا من
مؤسساتنا